même si les réfugiés rentrent
progressivement dans les semaines qui
viennent une fois au rwanda les
problèmes ne seront évidemment pas
régler dans un quartier de kigali la
capitale dévastée par cette guerre des
enfants des adolescents
là encore sont livrés à eux mêmes ils se
sont organisés en bandes ayant pris
possession des ruines c'est un reportage
d'eric monnier et vincent maillard
retour à la sainte famille
après la tragédie les réfugiés ont enfin
quitté cette église de kigali où ils ont
tenté de trouver refuge et mois durant
lequel son parcours mais ils ont laissé
derrière eux ces enfants des orphelins
pour certains les autres sont simplement
sans nouvelles de leurs parents ils
vivent là on contre pas dans l'ancienne
école primaire dorment planches et
vivent ensemble ils sortent peu parce
qu'ils ont peur tout juste de temps à
autre pour visiter quelques maisons
abandonnées et tenter d'y trouver de
quoi survivre ils ont même désigné un
chef de bande
sans doute tout simplement parce qu'il
est le plus âgé il a 18 ans j'ai fait
une liste des dix-neuf enfants qui
vivent là pour que d'autres ne vient pas
s'incruster
ils peuvent passer une nuit ici après
doivent partir une ébauche de règles
communes qui n'évite pas la violence
la loi du plus fort est la seule qui
préside depuis déjà longtemps à kigali
ça c'est un coup de couteau que lui a
mis un type qui s'appelle saligue nos
mains mais on l'a fait déguerpir le seul
à bénéficier vraiment de la solidarité
du groupe
c'est jean d'amour sans eux il serait
mort que nous a donné une bouteille
d'alcool frelaté et après on a eu des
maux de ventre et en à vos mains
et voilà maintenant je suis aveugle
c'était il ya un mois
deux autres enfants n'ont pas survécu à
l'expérience ils disent qu'on leur l'a
promis ils attendent de l'aide
l'un d'eux a même décidé de recommencer
à étudier les autres disent que pour ça
on verra plus tard